let's see you'll be some
out
Oh wrong with junior
[Applause]
laughing and crying at the same time
[Music]
when I was a kid I was fat yeah
anybody else play goalie yeah yeah I was
a fat kid and once you're a fat kid if
you're a fat kid you know that'll haunt
you the rest of your life like the ghost
of gogurts past it's always right there
and I've struggled with my weight my
whole life one second I'm fat and I'm
skinny then I'm fat then I'm skinny one
second I'm Jonah Hill and then I'm Jonah
Hill and then I'm Jonah Hill and then
I'm Jonah Hill and I just want to be
somewhere in the middle seth rogen and a
couple years ago I was dating this woman
and she was way out of my league and I
knew and she knew it and I was
uncomfortable the whole time cuz I met
her when I was skinny and I knew the fat
she was gonna drop and I was gonna get
fat again
I just knew it I knew it in the year and
a half into the relationship it happened
you know you get comfortable after a
year and a half you gained that Netflix
15 or whatever and that's what happened
I got fat again and had a sneaking
suspicion that she wanted to leave me
because I looked at her phone when she
was in the shower and this is what she
told her friend she texted her friend
she was like hey uh I think I'm gonna
leave Chris and her friend was like why
and she was like he's starting to look
like a fat Peter Dinklage
ouchies like Peter Dinklage is handsome
but fat dink is not what I'm going for
so I freaked out I was like I gotta lose
some weight
I gotta lose weight fast I want to stay
with this girl you know and I looked at
the back of the weekly paper and there's
an ad for a boxing boot camp I was like
that seems like a good idea it's eight
weeks five days a week 6 a.m. to 8 a.m.
and but it was taught by these like
Irish Gold Glove boxers like fresh off
the boat Irish guys I didn't understand
a word they said they're just
like they sounded like bono in
Reverse right
but there are really good trainers and I
was really into this so I started like
training I start boxing I'm like jumping
rope I'm running I'm starting to like
cut weight and all this stuff I'm really
into it
my girlfriend leaves her laptop in my
apartment whether gchat open I had to
take a snoop I had to and I took a look
and she told her friend she was like hey
I think I'm gonna this DJ I was
like you're gonna a DJ have fun
having bedbugs and paying for his
rent that's some I get
mad right and I look him up and this guy
is beautiful this guy's fine his
he looks like Persian common
imagine handsome ass common with like a
hookah in his mouth that was sexy
he's like a very beautiful man like
this and this is very embarrassing
but this is what I did I went on his
Facebook page and I printed out a
picture of him and I put it in my locker
at the gym it was a moment of weakness
but I needed motivation I needed to lose
weight and I was like I'm gonna picture
this up in my locker I do
that this gay guy in my class is like is
that your boyfriend he's beautiful like
no it's not my boyfriend I'm
gonna beat that guy I mean
I'm getting all amped I'm getting ready
in this class I'm like I've conflated
these two things like becoming a boxer
and getting my girl back and one day I'm
in class right and there's like I'm
sparring and you spar with random people
this one day I spar with this guy who's
like six - right
he's like I'm like five Dinklage you
know I am NOT tough this guy's very tall
and but we're just doing body blows
we're sparring we're only allowed to hit
each other in the body and stuff and I'm
like a little intimidated but whatever
I'm trying to beat up person common
right now I don't give a so I'm
punching this guy in the stomach right
and he blocks himself really close to
his stomach and I punch them and it
punch him in the nuts and I'm like I
didn't punch you I punched you in the
stomach but you're blocking too close to
your body this is too close if you block
right here I'm gonna punch you in the
nuts you need to block out here he's
like would've bro I punch him again boom
in the nuts cuz I can punch me in the
nuts I'm like no you punched you in the
nuts and they comes and he sucker
punches me in the face and my face
explodes and there's just blood
everywhere down my Schurman like
you dude boom and I take this crazy
swing at him and we're just taking these
weird haymakers at each other the class
stops the class stops circles around us
one of the Irish coaches like finally
some boxing in here
I'm like yeah I love this
after the class the boxing coach is like
hey after the eight weeks do we open up
the gym for a fight night we invite a
couple of the boxers from the class to
fight you can invite your friends and
your family and stuff it's at nighttime
we have ringside er girls and announcers
and referees would you want to
participate in that and I was like yeah
I want to do that I'm gonna invite my
girlfriend I'm looking a boxing ring I'm
gonna beat some up and I'm
gonna win her back
that was my plan I show up the day of
the fight I asked my coach Who am I
fighting he's like oh you're fighting
the guy you punched in the nuts I'm like
this guy's 6 2 he's but he's like a
blonde buff 6 foot 2 Blanca he was buff
when he got into the class if he wasn't
an 80s movie his name would be like rad
Chad masters and I already pissed him
off I'm like this guy's gonna
murder me this is not what I'm going for
you know what I mean I'm nervous and I
was like I don't know what to do is
there a fight I call my dad my dad's an
old Cuban man Cubans love boxing he's
like my own mr. Miyagi send your Miyagi
so I call my damn like papi that's what
I call him cuz he's my dad not cuz he's
pit bull I say I say papi my fights
tonight I need some advice what do I do
let's see you beat the up
that's how you do and I'm like that's
great dad the guys six foot two and he's
like okay yeah you're gonna lose you are
no chance me you're not gonna beat this
guy up I don't know do the sign of the
Cross or some blue head er some
actually you know what the only way
you're gonna beat him is psychologically
you need to get inside that guy's head
okay he's more scared to lose to you
then you are to lose to him okay so do
some crazy get in his head if he
thinks he can lose you at least in a
little window opportunity to him up
now it's like okay thanks so I was like
that's kind of add to all I got what am
I gonna do this it's like a huge you
know and I'm like alright be weird and
crazy act like an idiot so I was like I
got a day and so I was like alright imma
buzz my head with I blast my head with a
beard trimmer like a fugitive running
from the law I looked all crazy
I wore these dirty bloody basketball
shorts from when he punched me I never
watched them they're down to here I wore
mismatched socks all the way up to my
knees like a rodeo clown I wore
these dirty chucks I was the only boxer
that not wear a shirt that night I've
got a tattoo of some scars I look crazy
I look like a out-of-work
Juggalo and so I show up again the ring
my girls they're my friends are watching
there's comedians there I was like I
better win I'm gonna get heckled
or dumped or some right so I show
up I'm in the ring the announcer comes
over he's like hey what do you want me
to say about you
and I was like call me the Cuban Missile
Crisis
and he announces means like Chris the
Cuban Missile Crisis Garcia I'm like and
then a part of my crazy plan was to like
I'm not gonna look before the fight when
we knocked gloves I'm not gonna look
this in the eye he's gonna
look down at me by 6 inches and just be
like I got you you punch me in the nuts
I'm will kill you so I just
like ignored his face and I just
Slingblade in my face
and I just I ended up staring at his
nuts I was just like the fight
starts to mesmerized by his nuts and he
just like poo punches me like uppercut
two uppercuts and I'm like oh and
there's blood just going down my chin
and that's just down my chisel like oh
and I'm like this is not what I'm going
for right here I'm not trying to get
beat up in front of this fool so I get I
get close I'm just running around all
crazy and then he comes close and I
punch him in the nuts and he's like dude
he's like you nut puncher and he
pushes me across the ring and I'm like
yeah and I'm feeling yeah or even a
fight before but your adrenaline is
insane and I see my girl and stuff and
I'm like aah
and I run towards the guy like flailing
you at him tonight I hug him I start
punching you in the back of the head
like this like he's like this dogs like
this
it's nuts and the referee pulls
me aside and he's like he's like stop it
you're out of control and I spent my
bloody mouthguard out on the Canadian I
love this noise you know my boxing coach
brings me into the corner and he's like
hey come over here you need to relax
and I was like okay I'll relax fine and
he's like I put you against this guy
because I think you could beat him up
you have a lot of heart and you put a
lot into this also you're left-handed
and he's right-handed so he's only used
to boxing right-handers you kind of have
an advantage in this weird way so when
he comes in with a hook you duck it you
enter it like towards the stomach and
you just punch him in the guts punch him
not in the nuts in the guts just bust
his guts and I was like all
right I come in he comes into the hook
oh god damn it and then we start
fighting some more we're pushing each
other around it's kind of crazy and I'm
like all right I'm just waiting for this
hook to come in he comes he punches me
again and he punches me again and my eye
just immediately swells up it looks like
a raw hamburger patty / butthole
I couldn't see it my eye was too close I
was just like this and I was like oh
dude and like time froze and I'm just
looking at my girlfriend juice I'm like
well it was nice knowing you I'm about
to lose and this is gonna be
terrible I'm imagining her I'm imagining
Persian common just her super
hard
just ramming her I'm thinking
about my dad being like you
disappointment
I came to America for this you
know and I'm like all right we boxed him
or he comes in with the hook and I just
bust him in the gut I bust him
in the gut and then I hit him right
right above the dick super like right
here
and he goes huh like this
like don't punch me in the nuts don't
punch me in the nuts and his hands are
down here and he's he's like right in
front of my face and his face is exposed
his gloves are down and I just go boom
and I clocked his ass and he fell and I
beat him psychologically he just laying
there flopping around like a
fish and they called the fight and it
was over and I'm like aw oh and my
girlfriend walks her she like runs
around towards me like Adrian and rocky
or whatever and she's like Christian and
she comes and she throws her arms around
me she's all horny
she got super horny she just let me beat
up some big ass dude she gets all horny
and she's like where'd you get these
muscles from and she starts grabbing
these weird muscles that are gone now
but she was like grabbing these weird
muscles and I realized I was like you
haven't touched me in over two months so
that night I took her home I showed her
what the Cuban Missile Crisis was all
about I won her back and then I broke up
with her
[Applause]
you guys have been great my name is
Gracia